fête tu joues je comprends allons-y
maintenant tu prends beaucoup trop de coups avant
de descendre il y a un aspect viscéral à
la précision et à la science de la boxe que
je n'ai pas vu un film que
tu ne peux plus trouver comme ça
pense à elle  pas beaucoup frappé papa ouais
tu devrais voir l'autre gars
gaucher parle d'un combattant du haut
tombe vers le bas apporte Billy Hope
Majah
je cherche un emploi peut-être placer un
échange tu ne pourrais pas gérer les règles ici
mais je peux  ne perds pas ma fille je te donnerai
tout ce que je peux
rejoins-nous alors que nous montons sur le ring avec
Jake Gyllenhaal et le réalisateur Antoine
Fuqua n'ira pas à temps apporte le
grésillement du parc
c'est une belle histoire une histoire d'espoir
histoire de rédemption et  c'est un
cadeau authentique, voyez l'incroyable
transformation de Jake pour devenir le boxeur
Billy espère que ce sera à son tour un
combattant professionnel immédiatement vous
entrez dans votre yo et entendez des
experts de la boxe de la vie réelle sur la façon dont les
cinéastes brouillent les frontières entre la
réalité et le film que j'étais  comme oh oh attends
c'est un film le plus important c'est d'
apprendre à être un père
c'est pourquoi je veux rendre le film
désactivé tu peux faire fleurir oh c'est
ton moment c'est ta maman
tu contrôle ton destin la
boxe est quelque chose que j'aime
un train tous les jours  Je suis avec des boxeurs tout
le temps que je trouve être les athlètes les plus
vulnérables de tous parce
qu'ils vont même se piéger sur le
ring à chaque fois avec un coup de poing au
bon endroit
est un enveloppement rentrez tôt à la maison et vous pouvez suivre un régime
vous devez  avoir quelque chose à l'intérieur de vous
quelque chose c'est comme un interrupteur tu
sais que beaucoup de combattants auraient pu être
le gars le plus gentil et le plus gentil qui lui a dit et lui a
parlé et quand ils allument un
interrupteur et tout le monde est là pour voir
quelqu'un se faire assommer même dans des foules
hostiles  donc l'énergie de la boxe est comme si c'était
comme si quelque chose était l'intensité est difficile
à décrire alors j'ai dit comment puis-je
capturer
cela souvent alors je voulais explorer cet
espoir de Billy